gentlemen every time someone steps up
and says who they are the world becomes
a better more interesting
place you can start the meeting now the
meeting is over you're late you missed
roll call and the tutorial on using the
new copier 6 years and no matter how
hard I try I still can't get you to
understand The Importance of Being
punctual maybe you should just give up
and accept me for who I am no I will
break you right now while you were out
being tardy I was harded work devising a
special punishment I've crafted an
intricate personal high five with
everyone in this office EX accept you
what but you hate high fives yes every
minute of it was hell but it'll be worse
for you Squad
dismissed goodbye
DS salute into a fanny wagle goodbye Bo
the Snake Charmer goodbye
Jeffers that's a butt bump goodbye
sanago double fist bump reverse
explosion into a Pete towns
strum all right that was terrible but
it's over now and I made it through
goodbye Leonard from Xerox what no no
the copy guy okay Amy I know you're in a
lot of pain but we don't have any meds
here you just got to try not to focus on
it can you distract her I got this hey
they come out with any new binders
recently I don't want to talk about
binders Rosa all right that was my big
gun she's just going to feel this not
necessarily I was just checking to see
if there's anything we can do to help
and I hate to say it but I think there
is oh you think he's going to get me
drugs from evidence uh no something way
weirder is happening hit it
Jeff it
push
it push
it I'm definitely
distracted what is that human blister
want now does she intend to demote me
even further or perhaps she'll transfer
me to the swamps of New Jersey so I can
Patrol the sinkhole where she was
spawned or it's possible the
announcement has nothing to do with you
oh good than you baral you're right
maybe mine wants to inform us all that
she's a chen a what a chen a Korean
toilet ghost lives in an ouse wraps her
hair around your throat and chokes you
to death while you move your bows you
know what I will give you $6,000 if the
announcement is she's a chen okay
everyone I have some news the madin W is
a Korean toilet ghost boring we already
knew that madon wch is dead say what now
I guess you should be very proud of
yourself I know things aren't exactly
way you want to be right now but uh I
promise you they will approve thank you
Captain every time someone steps up and
says who they are the world becomes a
better more interesting place
so thank
you ladies and gentlemen we are gathered
here today to answer an age-old question
right what's Amy's deal she's single no
we're dating come on the question is who
here does the best impression of Captain
Raymond Holt you will be judged on voice
body language and overall lack of flare
everyone will perform the same scenario
Captain halt eating a marshmallow for
the very first time let the halt off
begin what is this glutenous monstrosity
before me the sugar in this is quite
sweet that's your halt impression I
could hear him doing that looks like a
sticky pillow I don't care for it
classical
music what's going on here what are you
doing Captain hey nothing just eating
some marshmallows care for one
marshmallow I knew it is uh everything
okay Santiago no I lost my ring did you
see where it went
actually it's behind one of these three
doors why don't you pick one are you
trying to Monty haul me it's
unbelievable I don't need m Monty Hall
ruining my place of work when Monty Hall
has already ruined my home life come on
Sir the math thing isn't the problem
night shift's keeping you and Kevin
apart you two just need a bone what did
you say don't say it again I said you
two need a
bone
how dare you detective Diaz I am your
Superior officer bone what happens in my
bedroom detective is none of your
business bone don't ever speak to me
like that again
what's with the cast I spray my wrist oh
no what happened don't worry about it
I'm fine yeah geez Amy back off leave
the guy alone all right head up
everybody bring it in bring it in so he
wouldn't say what happened which can
only mean one thing he's in a fight club
no he did it doing something he's
embarrassed by like smiling only
question is how do you hurt your arm
smiling could be a sports injury I spred
my wrist in college playing field hockey
men's field hockey yeah it's much more
violent than the women's game we're not
allowed to wear anything that protects
our breasts attention everyone I can
hear you speculating about the nature
and origin of my injury from my office I
tripped over an uneven sidewalk I did
not think it was relevant to your jobs
the jobs which you should all be doing
right now get to
work do you want to know how I actually
hurt my wrist yes I was hula hooping
Kevin and I attend a class for fitness
and for fun my god I've mastered all the
moves the pizza toss the tornado the
Scorpion the oopsy
doodle why are you telling me
this because no one will ever believe
you no
no you sick son of a no sign of BR
out here did you hear anything on the
wire no it never came back on do you
think he's okay what do you hear yes I
do do that's the jingle of Cheddar's
collar and that's his
bark oh it's our Fluffy
Boy good dog good dog oh Mr cheddar how
I've missed you we both have okay suit
yourself hope you like kid's birthdays
hey everyone someone just volunteered to
be DJ
bday here at the Fun Zone we live by one
rule when it's your birthday you're
always cool parents kids are all the
same watch as I do a dance to your
name
dere
D again so again your Alibi is a
mysterious stranger handed you the gun
made you put your prints on it robbed
the store and then hid the gun in your
underpants Well yeah if you say it like
that it don't sound believable oh hey
Captain did you get my report on the
finle murder oh yeah I looked it over
nice work good thanks
Dad why is everyone staring at me you
just called Captain Hol dad you said
thanks Dad what no I didn't I said
thanks man do you see me as a father
figure Peralta no if anything I see you
as a bother figure cuz you're always
bothering me hey show your father some
respect I didn't call him Dad no no no
no Jacob I take it as a compliment it's
not a big deal I called Vivian mom once
and she's my fiance guys jump on that Bo
has psychosexual issues old news but you
calling Holt daddyy daddy is not on the
table here but you did call him dad dude
you shut up you've done nothing but lie
since you got here all right all right I
was lying about the hold up but the dad
thing that happened he admitted that his
Alibi was a lie it was a trap all part
of my crazy devious plan I believe you
thank you son you want to talk about it
later over a game of catch I'd like that
damn sir you took that shonet to the
house how you feeling let me take stock
my equilibrium is a skew my vision is
partially impaired and I'm clearly
slurring my words to put a fine point on
it your boy's turned well well well
there's only a minute left and you are
six bucks down I don't think you guys
are going to make it hang another Shar
this one's hot it was sitting on the
radiator he's never going to make it yes
he will just don't breathe let the
liquid into your
lungs 5 4 3 2 Closing Time cops
[Music]
wi all right fine the bar is yours
but we're keeping this come on before we
all go home and pass out I want to say
how sorry I am that I deserted you
earlier I want you to know that I care
about you all so very much each and
every one of you Bo Santiago Diaz
Hitchcock
SC are you eating an Italian sub for
breakfast I am but Amy said I should eat
more veggies so I got extra pepper
smart excuse me you need to watch
yourself I'm sorry cop all right let's
everybody just stay calm here oh what
are you going to arrest me for dancing
you call that
dancing this
is
dancing what is happening I'm diffusing
a
[Music]
situation dancing happened must capture
image of a
lifetime why is my phone always dead I
paid $13 for it don't worry Jak I got
it no my hands are covered in butter
from making butter come on it must
record must record camera on all right
here we go dancing over situation de
used
no jackpot let's do this and how am I
supposed to get all the way up there
gracefully boost my bottom I'm boosting
boost my bottom I'm boosting
boosting all
right stick shift I can't drive stick
shift you're going to have to drive how
my leg doesn't work sir I am a dancer I
will be your legs
clutch in okay clutch
out we are the best driver in the world
guys I have a great idea for a prank
before Hol comes in I'm going to put ink
on the podium where he puts his hands I
don't think you fall for that I did how
I haven't even opened this yet I guess
it's unrelated Captain hold hates pranks
this is going to backfire man G fine
I'll tone it down I'll move his Podium a
foot to the left what he'll be so angry
okay 5 in 5 three three one one all
right I'll move it a half inch fine it's
your funeral oh my
God worst prank ever so stupid Holt's
not even going to notice good
morning you guys it the podium
is you're crazy how did you pull this
off on my first day here I asked Jeff to
tell me about everyone told me you were
a great detective but the one thing you
couldn't figure out was how to grow
up
well I think you finally figured it
out well thank you sir I couldn't have
done it without you over the years
you've sometimes referred to me as
something of a father figure did I I
didn't realize that but I want you to
know if I had had a son and uh he had
turned out like
you I would be very proud of
him thanks
Sir
W wasn't expecting to get this emotional
it's not bad for an old robot
huh
s sir did you just make a joke I believe
I did yes I guess in the end we rubbed
off on each other quite a
bit Tyler your sex
movie t that right it was
[Music]
perfect